des rires d'enfants les doux rayons de
soleil de fin d'après midi une partie de
soccer improvisé la vie pleine entière
vrai
36 enfants des orphelins abandonnés
vulnérables ont fui les horreurs des
bombardements ils sont venus en quête de
sécurité relative dans cet orphelinat de
lviv nina n'a que 16 ans dès le début de
l'invasion et l'a parcouru près de 1500
kilomètres pour arriver ici un voyage de
deux jours organisé par l'orphelinat de
l'itie junk où elle logeait pour fuir sa
mère alcoolique
vider le moral comme
nina savoure la tranquillité de le vivre
mais elle demeure rongé par l'inquiétude
sa soeur est resté alessi jones
bombardés quotidiennement
vos va m la nourriture de l'orphelinat
qui lui rappelle chez lui ils s'ennuient
de faire de la mécanique pour passer le
temps mais ils apprécient ses nouveaux
camarades il a été évacué de l'es6 jones
qui lui aussi au début de la guerre
n'a que 16 ans mais trop d'expérience
pour son âge c'est sa deuxième guerre
après celle du donetsk en 2014 il se
rappelle s'être fait réveiller par trois
explosions dans son jardin la honte à
damas le des espaces heitz
il y mourra taxe très frustré de grazac
encore à banias où il est
sacha parle au téléphone avec sa maman
restée à zaporizhya elle l'a envoyé seul
loin du danger la semaine dernière bien
sûr ouest
il n'a que 15 ans il a fait le trajet en
train en discutant avec des étrangers
sacha est venu à l'orphelinat à pied de
la gare
il se promet déjà de rentrer à la maison
après la guerre selon l'unicef environ
73 mille enfants ukrainiens fui les
zones de bombardements chaque jour
depuis trois semaines qu'ils soient
séparés de leur famille ou accompagnés
de leurs parents ils doivent être
protégés
de nombreuses familles évacuées arrive
toujours à lviv mais l'exode des
réfugiés a diminué depuis quelques jours
après le chaos aux frontières et à la
gare de vivre une meilleure organisation
xénia adolescente de 16 ans elle-même
réfugiés qui dort dans un théâtre depuis
son arrivée à lviv il ya une semaine
accueillent les déplacés en quête de
sûreté et de direction
[Musique]
sourire câlin pour ce qu'elle reconnaît
une simple présence rassurante
c'est important de leur faire sentir
qu'ils sont chez eux dit elle on m'a
reçu cette façon là ici ça enlève du
stress
vient n'arrive de quartier avec ses
trois enfants roslan maria et ivagnas il
essaie de trouver l'autocar vers
cracovie en pologne viana voulait rester
chez elles mais les bombardements se
sont dangereusement rapprochés il y a
trois jours
fini les bruits incessants d'explosion
même s'il y a quelques sirènes d'alarmé
lviv ce n'est rien comparé à la peur
constante d'être bombardés
dans leurs bagages que l'essentiel pas
de jouer mais beaucoup de vêtements pour
les enfants maman s'occupe de tout à
l'orphelinat dans cet environnement
sécuritaire les enfants 11 même penser à
leur avenir
boutboul
les russes ne l'emporteront que s'ils
nous tuent tous et ça n'arrivera jamais
déclare sasha
dans cette guerre où ils sont forcés de
grandir trop vite les enfants arrive
miraculeusement à conserver un peu de
leur innocence ils si philippe leblanc
radio canada vivent en ukraine